ladies and gentlemen please welcome back
2015 rookie of the year a four-time
all-star
2016
national league mvp
and world series champion
number 17.
chris bryant
it's kyle hendricks he is the starting
pitcher for the cubs today been a really
rough goal for kyle here six and change
era in the second half he's got a 969
era over his last five starts belt over
the second
a little slow roller
wisdom
much too late
and wisdom would have been better off
just holding that one with the speed of
wade
so he gets a hit but it's an infield hit
so belt over to third and now brian
let's listen
his old teammate wilson contreras the
catcher and he's facing an old teammate
kyle hendricks a
very loud ovation and everybody's still
standing as bryant comes to the plate
here belted third weighted first two
strike count
struck him out with a change up nasty
leone was the guy who started the
bullpen game on sunday against the
dodgers and had a very strong first
inning
struck him out one away
he struck him out there's that high
fastball three up three down with a
couple of strikeouts here is wilson
contreras and as you see dom leone is
still in there for the giants and he's
had a full count to all four of the
batters
belt
one away three and one
left field in comes chris bryant well
that's too strong
from dave leon now buster posey he
grounded out softly to third his first
time belt over there at first
right-hander hendricks swing and a miss
strike three
josie kind of reaching for an off-speed
pitch toward the outside edge came up
empty harleen garcia is coming in after
two solid innings by dom leone 48 games
this season with a 2.3 ara and
there's a bunt
and garcia will throw out hendricks at
first tommy stella covering so well done
there by hendricks and now the cubs have
a runner in scoring position with two
down and the lead off man ortega coming
up 0-2
struck him out with the slack one down
and here comes kb again
they got him to foul tip it into
contreras mid kyle sometimes will he
calls it his delayed pronation change up
or kind of hold that grip a little bit
longer to make sure the ball doesn't
float back into the hitter's uh happy
spot
but yeah that uh glove side change after
throwing it across the plate frank
schwendell
that's drilled out towards center field
going back gustrebski at the wall and
it's gone frank the tank will touch them
all and it is one nothing his 12th of
the year they're trying to go in with a
fastball it's up and out over the plate
it's got that good level swing that's a
swing and miss for a lot of guys with
that launch angle uppercut swing people
get on top and ride that one out of here
tell for the 52nd time comes in to pitch
for the giants 2-2
got him swinging with the high fastball
high forcing fastball and when you're
getting good movement down at the bottom
of the zone with two different pitches
it really opens up the top of the zone
two out space is empty patrick wisdom
who in the bottom of the fourth
that one is right there 97 miles an hour
called strike three well now the town's
going to bat for himself with two down
and nobody on he's ready to pull the
trigger
he is and he lines one down the right
field line base hit
go figure zach littell with the second
giants hit of the game that's the first
time he's ever had a hit in a big league
game give me the ball that is a moment
he will remember forever 88 mile an hour
sinker with an exit velocity of 97 miles
an hour jose alvarez out of the giants
bullpen the captain will hold david
bodie on it first it's the homemade
self-appointed captain of the team now
one and one
alcantara on the ground to short
crawford that's one la stella that's two
alvarez gets the double play ball the
giants get the runner to third with only
one out or lemon wade junior two-two
that one is off the end of the bat kind
of a bloop and it's going to fall base
hit belt'll score lamont wade is going
to try for second and he gets thrown out
by a lot so two down the giants do tie
the game one to one that was not a real
good decision from lamont to try to get
to second when you're out by that much
but the giants get the game tied we go
to the bottom of the six the giants have
tied the game up and look who's at the
plate it's matt duffy the former giant
3-2
strike three call perfect pitch right
there so now ortega at the top of the
lineup now the pitch
swing and a miss he struck him out with
a fastball they try and handle trevor
mcgill on for the 22nd time crawford at
first nobody out
that ball is smoked high and deep to
left field and there it goes to the top
of the bleachers evan longoria has put
the giants ahead with a two run-up big
fly wow a nice short compact swing from
evan longoria
a fastball this one down mcgill had been
trying to go the top of the zone this
one he misses a bit down and evan
longoria we've seen this swing the short
compact swing that produces
easy power
now belt there's a drive to left field
way back there it's into the basket a
home run for brandon belt
the captain
with a sinking fastball
is supposed to be up but it ends up down
in in the middle and anybody who's ever
watched brandon belt hit that is his
sweet spot he loves that pitch a
lead-off walk
to crawford what a back he backhanded it
bare-handed by listella who throws out
wisdom for the double play
wow crawford with an outstanding grab
then the backhand like a behind-the-back
pass to second base
bare-handed by la stella play great
range great hands great
athletic ability the backhand flip on
the bag and then stella with a nice play
to barehand it and turn it and complete
the tremendous double play it's tony
watson in for the giants bullpen the
veteran lefty
the fax ball puts him away 93 miles an
hour right by him we're going to take a
look at that fastball after a steady
diet of fastballs down
at the knees tony watson goes with the
four-seam fastball great execution
consider for the cubs
another fastball and another strikeout
two in a row for watson here's wilson
contreras
in on the hands crawford gets one lester
to first and that
wraps it up a double play to end the
game and a great day for the giants and
they have won five in a row
you